my name is vincent o'shanna i'm a
stand-up comedian slash actor and the
newest member of valuetainment
today i'm going to show you what a day
in my life is like working here let's go
pulling into the office right now i've
never had my own parking spot but here
at valuetainment they really know how to
treat their employees
there we go
and i get it i could see how some people
would complain about the distance of the
spot to the building but i think that
says you know a lot about this company
and that it's health-conscious
[Applause]
what's wrong with a little hazing among
co-workers
i think of bill's character
uh here to my right is the bullpen hey
kai knock knock i'm busy okay in my bed
caught my back he's busy maybe i'll tell
you later kai and over here we have eric
and chris and chris what's up dog guys
so vinnie he thinks he's funny
literally nobody else thinks so and then
she goes unfortunately he passed away
pasta because he's italian and he's dead
all right tough room hey favorite did
you get the whole pasta the bit with the
okay maybe next time guys well i heard
him say this joke it was like
some not pasta like
hostile pasta
um i thought it was funny um this is the
break room my favorite room the
amenities are off the chain we have an
oxygenated water machine right here we
got a coffee machine with a tv on it
guys that's how we roll a valuetainment
we got two microwaves and we got two
refrigerators this is my pizza right
here obviously
okay who's the wise guy wise girl
anybody tyler do you know who did this
anybody don't front hey neil
neil these little rascals in this office
don't shy away from practical jokes
which i think keeps the office energy
light and fun
believe it or not this breakroom
actually doubles as my office oh my bad
excuse me trying to get through sorry
ladies all right
my bad uh you just come over here now
this uh you know it's uh it's quite
close if you think about it like in a
bilbo baggins hobbit lord of the rings
type vibe i have all my little
knickknacks here i got pictures of you
know my friends my family i'm here with
kevin hart and uh
this is my dog uh jimmy choo he uh
he's not with us anymore last year he
chewed on the wire
i'm sorry bro you just give me a minute
i'm sorry you gotta close this
i'm sorry
honestly i think it's just so annoying
when we're trying to just take a break
and relax and you can hear him
[Music]
thank you
i just want to get away from that guy
i can honestly understand why his dog
chewed on the wire
there's smart people there's funny
people
there's creative people there's uh all
types of people that come on
and then there's many so it's
well good so to have this opportunity
arise is truly a godsend and to have
somebody like patrick david who's the
ceo of valuetainment not only be
somebody that i like up to but now be
somebody that i consider a true friend
means the world to me pat how do you
feel about vincent o'shona
who
[Music]